in a move to rein in the rising cost of
insulin walmart is unveiling its own
private label brand the retail giant
says its products will save diabetes
patients
up to 75 of what they're paying now
which could cost hundreds of dollars a
month a vial of walmart's insulin will
now cost about seventy three dollars a
box of injectable pins
about eighty six dollars the american
diabetes association estimates 8.4
million people in this country
rely on those daily insulin injections
joining us now are lisa gill she's
consumer reports investigative reporter
for health and medicine and our dr david
agus good morning to you both lisa we're
going to start with you
i would imagine everybody benefits when
the prices are lower i don't know
anybody that doesn't want lower prices
on anything
but do some people benefit more than
others in this case
absolutely we know from multiple
nationally representative surveys over
a decade that when people cannot afford
medication they don't fill prescriptions
or they skip
doses and we also know from a very
recent survey of
of like nationally representative of
americans who have diabetes
that one out of every five people told
us just at the end of last year that
they struggled to pay
for all the for their supplies and for
medication so
this sort of move today with with
walmart is extremely helpful
also helpful for people who have
insurance but who may have not yet met
the deductible
so that means they may be paying a
thousand two thousand five thousand
dollars out of pocket before their
insurance even kicks in
and it also may be helpful for people
who have insurance but whose insulin
just simply
isn't covered uh so it gives them yet
another option which is a very
very good thing david some people may be
worried about the quality of this
insulin since it's so much cheaper will
the walmart insulin
be the same quality as as brand name
insulin products
oh yeah i mean it's being made by a
company called novo nordisk which is one
of the top three suppliers of insulin in
the country
and it's going to be quality i mean the
regulations now on generic drugs are
very good
walmart sells several hundred drugs for
four dollars
with no insurance cost a month so
these are quality drugs and they can
fight most diseases that we all face
so lisa what impact could walmart's move
have on this industry
oh it it it really could be huge and you
know they sort of
they're they're they've been a long time
leader in offering
low-cost supplies and as well as the
4.10
drugs to americans for a really long
time
hopefully here it will put sort of
continued pressure on pharmaceutical
companies to
keep those really great sort of of
pocket
discount programs coupon programs and
patient assistant programs
low and affordable so i would say the
more attention that is brought to this
issue
the the more that people realize that
they don't really need to pay more than
100 bucks or sometimes even 35 dollars
out of pocket
for their insulin it's a it's a very
very good thing hey dr agus
insulin in america costs up to 10 times
more than it does in other countries why
is that you know
it's a great question and certainly we
have a runaway train it's a predatory
practice it costs 10 times more because
they will be paid 10 times more and
that's not right you know when banting
identified insulin in 1923 he declined
to put his name on the patent
because he didn't think it right to make
a profit on something like insulin that
would save people's lives
so we have to go back toward value-based
pricing
in our country because otherwise it's
not sustainable
lisa do you think this is likely to have
an impact on the price of insulin
overall
um you know we we would hope so i mean
we we've already
some of my investigations have shown
that surprisingly
after the three big drug makers that
make insulin
were called before congress about two
years ago those companies started to
really try to offer direct to consumer
low
lower cost pricing either through coupon
programs or patient assistant programs
as a way to sort of mitigate this
problem and really cut out middlemen
who often just because of the the nature
of that system
can unfortunately artificially increase
prices that are felt by the consumer
it put pressure on them to lower prices
i think this move by walmart will
continue to do that and really shed a
light on
just how low those prices can go when
you go direct to consumer when you go
direct through a retailer like walmart
we're going
to go david but before you go random
question here we were told right before
we came on the air not to use the term
diabetics
that we should now say people with
diabetes because diabetics is considered
offensive is that true i just want to
make sure we all get it right
it is the standard not to say it's
people with diabetes and there's type 1
that requires
insulin type 2 that may or may not
require insulin
all right now we know dr david agus lisa
gill thank you both